[Music]
i like your intro thank you it's very
nice this is our own cooking confidence
coach nanny bubbe back with us in studio
and chapman automotive is sponsoring
this segment today we're going to learn
about the joys and beauty of dragon
fruit dragon fruit oh my gosh there's so
many different varieties and they are
called fun names like ones called david
bowie or bowie bowie bowie bowie yeah
what happened to me i don't know anyway
purple haze there's lots of funds in all
kinds of different varieties but let's
talk about three okay this is the
absolute red variety this is white and
this is yellow so let's cut in it you
want to taste it yeah absolutely and you
can find them at any grocery store uh
pretty much yeah so they didn't make it
into the united states until 2008
and then when they did there was a
agricultural agreement with vietnam
and so look at this are they are any of
them grown
in the united states now they are there
are big farmers in the temecula area of
dragon fruits in fact i've been to a
farm and actually talked to the farmer
and interviewed him and it's wonderful
so look at how easy that peels isn't
that fantastic look at that so easy you
want to taste it i'll cut your piece
okay there you go try that kind of like
when a kiwi marries a watermelon kind of
or has a baby with one how do you know
you're choosing a good one you don't and
sometimes how does that taste is it
sweet yeah okay all right let me just
wipe this because we're getting into the
white right here okay so this is the
yellow
okay yellow variety and this is actually
the very sweetest of all so just take
your spoon
into that
take a little taste of that while you do
that i'm going to cut into this white
variety which actually really doesn't
have much flavor at all
so how's that wonderful you sound like a
lot yeah this is very very sweet and the
white variety not so much so that's just
a little walk through all the varieties
of dragon fruit and the origin of it was
vietnam to america but very much found
in south america central america and
mexico that one actually has a little
bitterness to it it does and some people
say it is flavorless but nonetheless it
is beautiful and we are going to put
this into a dragon fruit salad so i can
imagine that really good yeah yeah
because it takes on the flavor of the
dressing so we're going to sprinkle that
in we're going to take the one that you
like the best
put it right into the salad
this is the one i like the best yeah oh
that's right that's true that goes into
the salsa
and now a little bit of feta
okay that's it for the salad we're going
to take the dressing what kind of
dressing you using so this is a blood
orange juice with a blood orange olive
oil a little bit of lime juice what does
that say my friend you can hold that
spread love life there we go a gift from
my daughter i love that uh oh i can't
hey can you open that for me yes ma'am i
hope so we'll move on to the salsa yeah
exactly
thank you very much on television i
wasn't able to so there we go isn't that
beautiful we'll toss it really quick do
we have time for you to taste it yes
absolutely it's very colorful isn't that
beautiful just imagine that on your
buffet at home or you know out for the
barbecue it's beautiful so i'll put just
a little bit right in here for you
with the dressing
okay and you can be eating a little of
that while we talk about the salsa and
by the way you put a little bit of basil
in there and i'm adding that last
because we're going to take it over here
to the salsa so can you eat cilantro
kendall yes can you i am one of those
who cannot eat cilantro yeah i have you
know there's people that have a genetic
deficiency for cilantro i'm one of them
so i and if you are you can separate and
use instead of cilantro parsley and or
basil which is what we're going to do so
here we have the summer salad i love
that isn't it good thank you so this is
the passion fruit right here the dark
red kind we're going to add to it some
onions there we go what would your
response to cilantro be i just hate the
taste of it oh it just it it's just so
it's it's not just yeah it's just really
bad also here is that yellow
uh
dragon fruit that you love and instead
of cilantro i'm putting in basil and
parsley
and everything should be salt fat acid
so here's the acid a little bit of lime
juice okay we're going to throw that on
here comes some french sea salt
right
would french sea salt make a difference
as compared to table salt just regular
oh yeah iodized table salt you don't
really ever cook with that it's either
kosher salt and finish with french sea
salt how's that and the fat so you want
to say if this is salt fat and acid
where is the fat all right we're running
out of time so i do want to taste this
okay where's the fat right there there's
the fat okay okay do we have time to to
make the margarita i think i've just
told in my ear we do not okay but off
camera we can make a margarita okay well
we will
isn't that beautiful i absolutely love
it look at that is is that great because
it was it has the acid and the french
sea salt
oh man that's really good you don't
think about putting sea salt into salsa
no but it's delicious yeah check out
nanny bubby's kitchen and garden on
social media and online
at nannybubby.com i also want to thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring the
segment and we will have more las vegas
now right after this
[Music]